stop hey name this actor
this next part is very difficult they're
going to take you
i want you to do that
[Laughter]
you were in that movie did you work you
worked with him yeah he was lovely
i always wanted to work with him oscar
schindler i could have with this one i
could have saved one more jew
i with this watch i i could have saved
i cry every time i think about it he's
the class oh
man when my father passed away
i got my agent received a handwritten
note from liam and it had been
i don't remember 10
years since i shot taken yeah and he
wrote on his own stationary this
hand written note that just was you know
my condolences i'm so sorry you know
it was just so classy and he was just
and when we were shooting he was so
professional and it was just
it was a great experience that's awesome
when you're heroes or when people that
you really admire
actually come through in a such a humane
way that you're like
wow this is what i always wanted these
people who i
you know i liked to be and when you see
that
that's awesome i love that yeah it was
yeah it was
great